I'm here speaking with uh Ms. Caroline
Doss, the president of Coptic
Solidarity. And we just finished up a
conference here in Washington DC,
talking about the plight of the Coptic
uh Christians of Egypt, the indigenous
Christians of Egypt. And um yeah, I just
wanted to talk with her and get some
information about how it all went and
what what the mission what Coptic
Solidarity's mission is all about. And I
guess uh you know to give the audience a
little preview, I'll summarize our main
issues of course, which is that the
Coptic Christians of Egypt are being
persecuted essentially and discriminated
against. Um if if you've watched any of
my videos or followed any of my articles
for the last two decades, I've been
talking a lot about this particular
topic, the Coptic Christians. Um you
know, the Coptic Christians are actually
the indigenous inhabitants of Egypt. um
they are they're actually uh according
to DNA studies the descendants of the
pharaohs and uh because Egypt before the
Islamic invasion in the 7th century um a
lot of people don't know this but the
Egyptians before the Arabs came were all
Christians and th those were the
descendants of the pharaohs and the
language that they spoke which we call
Coptic was actually the coronic language
um even though it was written with the
Greek alphabet because thanks to
Hellenism in a lot of uh Greek Greek
loan words even the word Coptic a lot of
people don't understand it's province
it's basically the Greek the Greek word
for Egyptian the English word we use
Egyptian comes from uh the Greek word
for Egypt and Egyptians which is iiptos
and then when the Arabs came in the 7th
century being lazy they just decided to
take the middle of the third syllables
gip iiptos and they called this gip and
it became over time kipp in Arabic and
then it came into the English
transliteration as cop. So that's really
it. And that's why my standing joke is
I'm a cop and don't ask me which police
person I work for because most people
don't even know what the word cop means.
Anyway, um so we all know what happens
to the cops of Egypt up until now their
percentage depending on who you ask
could be anywhere from 10 to 12 to 15%
of Egypt. And um you know they they
suffer from the sorts of things that we
know is part and parcel of Islamic
doctrine, Islamic law, Sharia. And so
the main contending issues that we are
always confronting is bans on churches.
Uh it's so hard to build a church. You
can't even renovate a church. You have
to get some kind of decree. The Egyptian
government tries to act like it's been
sort of ameliorated, but it hasn't. And
maybe we'll get a a little bit into
that. Um but that's one of the main
issues the the churches the darth of
churches only recently and once again um
they had to actually hold aerary
procession for a Coptic man because they
didn't have enough churches and they did
it in the streets and this has happened
multiple times before. Um and then of
course there's the regular uprisings. uh
maybe two weeks ago something in Mina.
They I wrote about it, but you know,
Muslims rose and attacked and burned
Coptic Christian homes because one of
their numbers had put on some mobile uh
adapter on his roof. And if you dig into
the sources, you find out that according
to Islamic law, a Christian home can't
be higher than a Muslim's home. And so
it was seen as some kind of a front and
they rose up and burned several homes
screaming Allah Akbar thereby
emphasizing the religious hostility and
the religious motiv motivation behind
the attack. And we also know about uh
another major issue is the attack on
Coptic Christian women and girls and how
they all disappear often. Uh they go to
school, they go to work and next thing
you know their phones turned off. They
never appear and uh the police say, "Oh,
they just ran away." uh even though they
were going to take a test or an exam in
college and didn't pack to leave. So
that's another one of the issues and
there's so much more to talk about but
uh we have Caroline Doss here who is the
president of Coptic Solidarity. So you
know why don't you start by telling us
uh what what you think we had this
conference we had um here on Capitol
Hill we had several congressman speak
and um yeah tell us what you think of
everything the mission and what's going
on what's on your mind. Okay, great.
Thank you for speaking with me today,
Ray, on this really important issue.
Yeah, we just wrapped up a two-day
conference uh which was very very
successful. Uh the conference uh time
frame included uh meetings with
different legislators. Uh so we were
able to continue spreading the word and
updating our uh local lawmakers about
the important issues um that are
happening right now. The conference also
included um a congressional briefing
which was really awesome and we were
fortunate and blessed enough to actually
have a witness who's a victim of
persecution. Uh this was a woman who had
been as a minor kidnapped and raped and
uh was presented with a national ID card
that now gave her a new name, a Muslim
name as well as identified her as a
Muslim. So it was really great to
actually hear from a victim and their
perspective. Also we had you know panels
and speakers uh that uh from different
parts of the world. We actually had a
speaker um speak on the persecution and
kidnapping and forced conversion of
Christian girls and women in Pakistan
which we don't really hear too much
about and apparently is um has been a
problem for a very long time there. And
he had also mentioned that they burned I
believe 26 churches in one year in 2023
which is something we don't really hear.
Sounds similar to what happens in Egypt,
like you know, like in August 2022 when
we had 11 churches accidentally burn
within a 14-day period. Uh apparently
fires only strike
certain uh houses of worship. Uh they
tend to be Christian though
consistently. And before that uh two
week streak uh where all these churches
were lighting on fire, there were many
other streaks before and they're
continuing afterwards. And uh we see
consistently that the government rules
them as accidental in nature within
minutes or hours after conducting a
thorough investigation. Um and there
seems to be you know that pattern that
is churches burn and there's no
investigation no real investigation. And
it also seems that the um Islamists have
changed their tactic. Uh previously it
was bombing the churches
right
um which gained a lot of attention. So
they there seems to be a shift right now
and now it's burnings and it seems that
they're a little bit more comfortable
doing that so that
there's less noise.
I've been following that closely. I'm
glad you bring it up because uh you know
for viewers what's been going on is uh
for years if you go back in the '9s
actually all the way back to the 70s
churches would always be attacked by
Muslim uprisings and mobs and for
whatever pretext whatever excuse it
would be part of the sort of collective
punishment. And I remember it would be
cuz I follow this maybe every year uh a
dozen churches would be attacked and
burned and then suddenly you know maybe
3 4 5 years ago all of a sudden they
stopped which ostensibly is great and
then they started again even more but
every single time it's an accident. The
the most recent one was actually less
than 2 weeks ago and um before that it
was maybe 3 3 weeks before the most
recent one another one did. And what
she's saying is that a church would just
catch fire and then the um firefighters
and the authorities would come and
before an actual forensic sort of
analysis would be conducted, they would
say it was an accident. It was faulty
wires. It was an overheated air
conditioner. It was a candle left in
place. And it begs the question, you
know, this would make sense if churches
weren't attacked beforehand by Muslim
mobs being angry and then all of a
sudden you're having this. But what we
went from is open attacks on churches to
now it's no longer open and the churches
are burning even more than before. But
the authorities are presenting it always
as some sort of accident. And so which
begs the question, is this business as
usual under a new guise, a a new
sophisticated guise or uh or have the
Coptic Christian people become the most
fireprone people on the face of the
earth that they just uh even though
churches to them are the most precious
thing because they can't build them and
their whole problem is getting enough.
But for some reason more than any other
Christian group in the world, they just
uh are always catching fire because they
don't know what they're doing. So what
do you think of that? You think it's a
coincidence? Absolutely not. I mean, I
would also like to point out, which
should have been obvious to the
government, or perhaps was obvious and
they just didn't care, that those 11
churches that burned in August uh 2022,
burned on the anniversary of
which is a was August uh 2013 when 80 um
the Muslim Brotherhood in revenge for
the CC revolution took it out on the
Coptic Christians because they were
perceived as being supportive of the
revolution that ousted the Muslim
Brotherhood.
Correct. And that coincided just with
that anniversary.
Yeah.
So, it was a coincidence.
I mean, that's what they want to show.
That's they're trying to imply. But you
also mentioned, and that's important. I
also witnessed it, which is, you know,
we had the actual witness of a woman, a
Coptic woman who was uh essentially
raped and coerced and by a Muslim man
until she literally had to flee the
country. And I think what was important
about that is, you know, when when you
hear these stories, we all hear the
stories of women being abducted and
raped and coerced and forced into
marriages, Islam, and you know, I don't
want to say I get jaded, but when it's
just in a written text, it's so hygienic
and just like a crime, but hearing this
woman say it and seeing the trauma and
how 20 years later she was still, she
couldn't hold herself and she was
crying, I think really underscores how
devastating all this stuff really is
above and beyond the written statistics
that we see. You're
right. You're right. There it's a it's
an attempt to break down our society,
our families, and uh that that's how
they go about it. They attack our our
children and and it starts actually she
mentioned that the assault started when
she was younger as a child, you know,
bullied by other Muslim children. And
and she also mentioned how, you know,
her Muslim friends, who she thought they
were friends, in the end they all worked
together and it was it was like it was a
conspiracy. Even though they smiled in
her face and she could trust them, in
the end they were all collectively
working together to basically groom her.
Correct. And then they were actually the
ones that took the picture of her that
was later used uh on the idea.
Right. Right. What they did is uh like
joking around or she was cold or
something. They said, "Hey, put this
scarf on. It's cold outside
and she just did and they took a picture
of her and then they started presenting
it as proof that she converted willingly
to
and she's veiled now and that was the
picture they used for the national ID
garden with her new name Fatima Fatima.
Yeah. And they give her a new name and a
new ID card which they didn't ask for.
Yep. Exactly. Yeah. It's something that
you see unfortunately very often. But
something we did talk about at the
conference which I think is really
amazing uh was during I believe it was
the end of the first day of the
conference. one of the girls that we
were um campaigning to be released for
was released.
So, she reappeared. Um
I believe her name might have been Mar.
Okay.
So, that was one of the girls that we
were um whose case we were pleading.
That's good.
It was amazing. So,
every every effort you make is is
definitely worth it.
You have one person come back after tons
of noise and and tons of advocacy. It
was definitely worth it. So what does
Coptic solidarity ultimately want? I
mean obviously he wants justice and
equality and freedom, religious freedom
for the Coptic people of Egypt and um
you know how does it go about doing it
and would you say it has been successful
or sort of meeting its mark or what what
else needs to be done?
Well, civil rights, equality, people
citizenship that that's really what
we're advocating for and it's basic
human rights. Um and and unfortunately
we're not seeing it in all aspects of
society when it comes to home houses of
worship. Um societal violence uh
education the um the positions for
government you know ku Christians as you
mentioned earlier roughly what 12 13 14
15%. But we don't see that equal
representation in government. So there
is no equal representation in
government. There's there's no
accountability for the crimes committed
against Coptic Christians.
Unfortunately, anytime you turn on the
news, there's always a new event, a
house, Christian home burning. And when
you watch the events that are occurring
in Armenia, they're not just like small
attacks. You're talking about mobs and
huge mobs of people
in the video in the video.
In the most recent video, which I
alluded to in Mina maybe two weeks ago,
it's good. Again, it was similar to
listening to the witness because often
times you can read about Muslims
uprising and burning homes. And again,
it sounds very, you know, academic and
neutral hygienic, but in this case, a
woman uh with her with her, I guess, her
phone, right? And she was holed up in
her home videotaping from outside and
she has metal bars on her windows. Makes
sense. And all you can see is just
Muslims, men, women, and children
burning, destroying, and screaming Allah
Akbar. And you can hear the woman
basically saying, you know, like, do you
see world? Look, world, what's
happening? Do you know what's do you
understand what's happening here? But he
gave a human voice and it really again
underscored what really happens instead.
It's not just a statistic. I think it
was Stalin who said, you know, you can
kill a million people and that's a
statistic. You kill one, it's a murder.
And that's the idea which is, you know,
putting a face and a voice to what
really happens. I think it's so much
more powerful when you experience it as
we did in these last two days in this
conference listening to people than just
reading about it in a in a in a news
report.
Yep. I agree with you. And actually what
really drives me is I'm I'm an
immigration attorney and my focus is
asylum law and I work with so many
Egyptians that uh flee the persecution
in Egypt and I I could say that I've
easily easily interviewed
2 3,000 Coptic Christians from Egypt and
I've had the opportunity to hear those
stories myself. Wow.
So I've had the opportunity to hear
about the
You're so similar.
There's there's definitely a pattern.
That's what I mean.
There's definitely a pattern, but you
hear and and they the same tactics are
used in in different areas, but at the
end of the day, it's the same thing.
There's no justice. So,
what's the worst thing you've heard in
your experience? The most, you know,
injust graphic, uh, you know, as much as
you can share.
You know, it's it's really hard to pick
just one story
because
there's just so many that are just so
horrible. But really, it's just
what comes to mind. Let's say like so
you know stories about let's say they
attacked our home. I've heard that one
many times while we were in it. You know
we we would all get in there and and you
know run to the balcony and like throw
what we can to kind of just you know
push them back but we were terrified
that we were going to get killed and the
moltos are coming in and we're putting
them out as they're coming in. Things
like that. I remember hearing one story
recently and and and
this one was the this one was crazy. So
this guy starts to tell me about how um
the Muslims got all together and they
attacked the Christians in the village.
And he says, "You know, I got beat. This
is what happened to me. And my wife and
my kid got hurt, too." And and I was
like, "Oh, wow. Did they break into the
house?" And he's like, "No, no, no. My
wife and my kid, they got they got beat
outside." I said, "Well, if they saw the
mob coming, why would they be outside?
Why wouldn't they be in the house?"
Because if they stayed in the house,
they were going to burn the house with
them in it. So I I thought that was
pretty shocking that, you know, women
and children had to come down and and
try and defend themselves um in the wake
of this like huge Muslim, you know, bomb
of violence. And that that was, you
know, something you just you can't
really imagine, you know, and you're
looking at medical records for the
injuries and and they're severe. And at
the end of the day, I always ask, you
know, what happened? Did the police
come? Surely someone must have called
the police
cuz you're talking about hundreds of
people on both sides.
And then usually the answer is yeah, you
know, everyone was calling, but they
they came after pretty much everyone was
beaten and on the ground. Um, you know,
the flames have already, you know, been
put out because they burned themselves
out. Um,
and what she's referring to so people
understand is that this is a very common
thing where the police finally respond
only after the mobs had their fill.
Yeah. after they've had their
had their fill now we're gonna come and
all right and and put a show and say
let's let's stop it literally hours
later
if and when someone's arrested what they
tend to do is they take it they take
from both sides and they do that so that
when they take him to the police station
in the event that the Christian
reconciliation in the event the
Christians insisted on filing police
reports because they're the ones at with
the loss obviously it's never the other
side um they basically uh forced them
into a rec reconciliation session saying
Listen, if you want to press charges,
you can't, but you're never leaving
here. Uh, expect that you'll be
transferred to state security because
this is, you know, a sectarian conflict.
And they and they will arrest. So, let's
say there's a a mob, you know, Muslims
rose up and attacked a Christian
village. They'll arrest 10 Muslims and
15 Christians. Correct. Because the
Christians fought back.
I was about to say that they always
arrest more Christians than they do
Muslims. And at the end of the day, the
Christians are forced into a
reconciliation session and there's no
criminal charges ever filed. On
occasion, I'll have a client that will
present me with a reconciliation
agreement,
which is basically you go to the uh
local elers's home and they make a
determination that you're just going to
shake hands, accept an apology, and walk
away. Although your home was burned,
and you know, you were beaten and you've
got all these medical bills and all
these injuries now that prevent you from
working,
you you don't get anything other than we
will let you live here.
So, for example, based on what you were
telling me, I this sounds very similar
to a highprofile case. A lot of them
have happened, but in this particular
case, I think it was 20 2016 maybe,
right?
Where Muslims rose up in a village and
attacked the Christians because of an
accusation that some Christian was
dating a Muslim woman, which is of
course haram, forbidden. It's okay for a
Muslim to date Christians and Jews, but
a Christian man can't uh because it's a
patriarchal society. Anyway, they
devastated the city and or the village
of the Christian homes and they went and
got this woman who somehow related, I
don't know if she's his grandma, but she
was I think 70s something. They pulled
her out, stripped her naked, whipped her
in the street publicly while jeering,
spitting at her and of course screaming
Islamic slogans like Allah Akbar and
derogatory terms about Christians. And
of course it was so bad because it was
videotaped that a lot of people in Egypt
saw it that Cece himself had to respond
and meet with her and you know tell us
what happened with the rest legally.
That's right. Yep. He promised justice
and eventually uh some of the asalants
were uh charged and convicted but in
2023 they were acquitted.
Yeah.
They kept they kept recusing the whole
thing, didn't they? like every year they
would kind of like uh
that was always the
they didn't want to Yeah. They would
appeal it and they would like a new
judge would step down or a judge would
step down, a new one would step in. In
other words, they were beating the bush.
They didn't want to get to it. And then
when it was all said and done and people
forgot about it, all these guys who were
on video doing what I just said,
stripping her naked and spitting at her,
were acquitted and the end result is she
had to leave the village, not them. And
they're all walking around free. And
another little twist, the asalants that
were acquitted
filed a uh lawsuit against her
for defamation.
Yeah. And there it is. That's justice in
Egypt. Um and you know, we can we can go
on and on. I mean, people know about
what's going on with St. Catherine and
we can talk about that later, but well,
thanks for your time, Miss Caroline
Doss, president of Solidarity, and uh
good work with what you guys are doing.
I hope I hope you keep making some
progress with Congress and trying to
ameliate the situation.
We'll keep going. Thank you. Appreciate
your time.